well I think if anything the financial
crisis which then swept over of course
to the real economy has shown us is that
it is not enough for business only to
create value for shareholders this was
the paradigm of the 1990s and the early
2000 everybody was demanding the
creation of shareholder value you will
not be able to create shareholder value
if you are not at the same time create
value for the society as such that's I
hope was the most important lessons that
we should be taking out of this recent
crisis that we have so I think this is
becoming more and more understood by
many of colleagues especially i would
say perhaps more clearly so by those who
are working in the real economy and i
hope that the financial world will also
start to better understand that it's not
all about money but that is also about
the values
I mean society at large has become
exposed to what a short-termism and
focusing on shareholder value can bring
and I think this wakening up now this
better understanding that this model is
outdated and that we have to replace it
with a new model a model that as I
mentioned before takes into
considerations the interests not only of
the shareholders of course of the
shareholders and shareholders will
always be I mean we have a
responsibility to them but we also have
to take the other interests of society
at large into considerations I hope and
I can feel it